[Music]
in [ __ ] up news submitted by nice
piece nice piece my space
never seen it I gotta show you it's
because I felt bad cuz I left a mouth
a female oncologist lost her license
after she had an affair with one of her
cancer patients what is an oncologist I
thought she was a gynecologist and she
was finger begging her patient that's a
doctor yeah
why I do not want to assume okay because
I always make assumptions and I'm always
wrong doctor that specializes in cancer
that's so cool it always diner cancer
and I was single and my doctor try to
save me by sucking my dick I'll be like
oh my god let me suck your cancer out of
you let me just suck it all out of you
don't save lives here we do holistic
passing she's so holistic all right so
does dr. Andy was dr. Skiba
sundaralingam that's not a real person
she's kind of I knew she was brown you
know what's name I know she looks kind
of scary I do she won't do it off the
gun she looks a little messy she got
some crazy in her eyes she does huh yeah
this chick eyes a beak 37 years old
oh she the kind of open person it's the
professionalism yeah that's the photo
professional people look old as dressing
I went to a restaurant the other day was
a 24-hour cafe his grandma waitress I
thought that [ __ ] was a college student
no she was yeah a grandma because of how
she was dressed she had like [ __ ]
like bands or some kind of like sneakers
on
varicose veins if you look closely now
you power tattoos dude that is literally
documented footage of one of the hardest
times I've ever laughed in my life like
arguably when you look at the video it's
really not that funny I wasn't that
funny at all I could remember how I felt
when I watched that video I get tears
laughs because you thought the same
thing when you realize that it wasn't a
tattoo
you were like oh or that man with his
girlfriend we thought I was too oh it's
cuz we called him his homie that's why I
should hug in jail baby dude I thought
like it was two very secure guy I'm here
enjoying the ride yeah at Disneyland and
it's two burly men in a [ __ ] tea cup
yeah oh that's I mean it's it's not
funny when you say it out loud it's
funny cuz of that accident yeah oh dude
that [ __ ] hurt my sides in my face dude
but then so me and Jess were there and
then it was literally like a 60-year old
lady but she dressed so young that at
first glance you know and it was late at
night so you know how like your vision
isn't as crisp right but from afar you
see this person that's 20 and as she
gets closer she ages a decade every and
by the time she gets you she's 60
something and you're just like what did
that Walker come from dude so it's
almost like her hair and clothes and
everything stayed the same age but her
skin everything is almost like a curse
dude like because you mistreated women
your whole life now you have a curse
that the most beautiful women when they
get close to you they just start to age
ah ah the house I'll figure out when
they're the hottest and I'll tell them
to stand like
what binoculars
which is Kirsty she goes i crusty that's
what you think in the phone and then you
just zoom up and you're like what's up
girl now you skiing a proxy dick-sucker
do so you can stare at her and have
somebody suck your dick I won't be
coming this guy dude what the [ __ ] can
we work so within days of telling her
patient that he has cancer
he starts she started flirting and
sexting him and that's easy
whoa eventually sucked the cancer having
sex with him and his home in her clinic
and even in his hospital bed readmitted
this is my only chance
I really have a crush on this guy before
he dies I must [ __ ] him
I mean I could kind of understand all
that right she made right he married
they don't mention that because it was
wrong with that hold on so yeah I'm
saying like up to this point it's like
okay fine whatever that's not I don't
think it's wrong either yeah but it is
against the dicks yeah the ethics and
stuff she this is grounds for her to
lose her license already yeah you can't
[ __ ] with the white coat on you have to
go well because it's she was treating
him yeah yeah she was treating him turns
kind of [ __ ] up is that all of a
sudden she just ends up telling him that
she she just likes this other guy damn
high school other patient say I like
this guy who has a little less cancer
he's gonna survive I mean that's [ __ ]
up no it turned out to be a colleague of
hers okay and then she breaking all
kinds of rules man you guys supposed to
be [ __ ] in the workplace and you're
not supposed to be [ __ ] a patient so
then she said that she followed in love
with her colleague and she was having an
affair with him and then so she ended up
just dropping the guy that had kept her
patient oh [ __ ] and so now that's when
this guy went to the board
this was a long [ __ ] you're a little
[ __ ] rat benefit from all that [ __ ]
in this round then he said like you know
she she like I was physically mash mash
eiated messy they see it initiated and
emotionally exposed and so now like you
know the loss of this critical
relationship it just defeated me and so
that's why he was just saying like
you're just [ __ ] up she used him and
then now he's like going through all
that I wouldn't even think about that
I'm like dude you're carrying my cancer
and giving me [ __ ] at the same time
what [ __ ] great deal is this you
should get an award that's true yeah so
she must really know it might be an
abuse of power I'm dying
that's like a teacher [ __ ] her
student and then she starts [ __ ]
another faculty yeah exactly
but they're both of age yeah you can
call it a college student oh okay
another one is like a therapist that's
[ __ ] someone that's but you know when
they get their medical license there's
certain like laws and ethics that they
have to agree to I'll just think me more
of the perspective I understand is
completely wrong
yeah thinking more of the perspective
the guy who has cancer and he could
possibly die but he's getting [ __ ]
before he dies well he's being a [ __ ]
about the writing part for sure yeah
it's like come on man you were a part
you you were tangoing today right
exactly
whether it was you just felt like you
victim because of the fact that he was
vulnerable though and like she did all
this [ __ ] you know what the shitty part
though is that you know he's doing it in
spite yeah he weren't really exactly he
would have been like while they were
[ __ ] him she would have reported her
yeah it was like like my guilty
conscience is telling me I gotta [ __ ]
report this after she dumps him yeah and
then after he gets dumped in he's like
well [ __ ] you I'm gonna tell on you or
lose your life it was the vulnerability
when he's putting the P and the V you
know yeah where was it then that was
empowering I tell you that I will say
this though I know you got cancer so I
hope you get better dude well they might
not be alive right now oh he made it
oh man I don't know I don't people that
survived cancer Yoshi
usually a doctor for six years and then
now like her entire career is over
because she'd be [ __ ] everything she
can't like we get her license it's just
gone it's not suspended it's gone like
that I think once you violate the code
of ethics it's like because she pled
just to do no harm she did not she did
pleasure maybe she could be a hooker or
an escort or or she could just go to
India and this should be a good double
yeah she could practice in another
country
yeah Europe yeah it's gotta be taken
boards over there did they say how long
they were doing this for 2015-2016 I
watch too much medical porn elaborate
every time there's some kind of
situation with Oh doctor my butt leg
it's broken
oh I'll help you out and she starts
sucking his dick what about his leg does
it ever get calms and then she's like
giving him a sponge bath and then she
just starts sucking his dick he's like
oh but I got a broken arm do they keep
up with that goes out set up right there
yeah I don't get that why do they like
just stick with your rod as Rob said you
know that's why people make fun of
American point it's always like bad
acting bad everything it's like the
continuity issues I know man I recently
saw some cartoon [ __ ] because I was
curious talked about it it's good the
stories are good was good she just said
she saw it don't put words in her mouth
it depends on what your it depends on
what you were reading are you watching
it yeah no you can't do that you're not
investing it to the store okay anyone
that you speak to they'll tell you Harry
Potter books are always better than the
movie well hold on let me stop you there
all right exactly this [ __ ] that you
were talking about where it has stories
and everything I was just curious what
cartoon porn look like period and I saw
this one where it was like it was
[ __ ] weird it was like Charizard or
something like some Pokemon [ __ ] and
then you could actually see like the
inside of what was happening that's
weird
you're on the Wii
outside you don't want to see The
Flintstones [ __ ] like when you're on a
porn site and then you see a pop up a
[ __ ] Lisa Simpson giving some [ __ ]
somebody yeah that's weird
that's weird man I want to see her suck
off a poo
I'm a normal human being okay with
normal likes and dislikes [ __ ] no you're
not uh-huh I think you have pretty long
I tell you I'll tell you [ __ ]
right now in the comments a lot of
people agree with me cuz they are woke
to the [ __ ] Conte Lokar they're weird
like you
[Music]
[Music]